let's say someone emails you for the
first time okay maybe they just started
a stage starting to account and then you
get this email hey our B would love to
meet for coffee I'm gonna be in LA yeah
what do you say to them I'd love to pick
your brain yeah I get on all the time
I mean it's it's part and parcel to
running something like this and what I
normally do is I try to steer them to a
stage 32 meet if I'm going to be at or
something along those lines because it's
very very difficult you know I'm not
going to downplay it the site has become
a monster
it takes up an enormous amount of my
time and then I do have my creative
pursuits you know I'm writing a book I
have a screenplay in development I have
a thing I'm producing that's in the book
so I mean it there's only so many hours
in the day and I give everybody
individual attention anyone who writes
to me on the site gets a response my
when you join the site you see my mug on
your wall and you know if you respond to
that welcome message I respond to every
single one of them one of my tech people
told me the other day that I have made
in the three and a half year history of
this site something like 29,000 posts on
the site that doesn't count private
messages that doesn't count emails that
doesn't count responses to Twitter at
you know so it's on and on and on so I
try to be as generous with my time as I
can but if I could take that single
person and put them into a collaborative
environment as opposed to just having
that one-on-one with me which they can
still have at this event but it's also
they're gonna meet maybe 30 40 50 other
people I'd rather do that I think it's a
better way and I think it's more
rewarding way in a lot of ways you know
I mean it's now this person has contacts
in my town or in LA so advice to someone
that's new to this town or new to New
York who sees someone of influence like
yourself and says you know what can I
pick your brain can I take you out to
coffee how do they see it from the other
person's point of view because they
probably see it as well their thing is
so important and they're then and it's
really you just got to meet me and
you'll be fine you're gonna you're gonna
know that I'm gonna go places I think if
you know if the approach is right I mean
it's not that I haven't done it before
you know I I did it actually at Sundance
like three times and enjoyed all three
conversations great conversations but
the approach to me was fantastic the
approach to me was
really enjoying what you're doing really
a big couple of them knew some of the
things that you know I was working on
had done the research to say you know
some of them knew me from a couple of
them knew me from raisin magazine and
said you know I used to read your
magazine and I love that that makes an
impact on you and that makes you want to
because you know again they're there
they've done their research they're
trying to cultivate a relationship I
mean I think that's great
I've done it with other people you know
maybe not even as much as I should have
in the past because I do think it's
important to have mentors and be able to
pick brain in the brains of people who
maybe are either more accomplished or or
a few steps ahead of where you are in
your career I think it's very important
but I just think that it's you have to
be understanding of a person's time and
space
and I think you have to be you have to
be understanding of you know I never
give anyone a direct no let's say what
I'll say is if I can't or like I'm
leaving town the next day or my
schedules packed or whatever I'll say
what would you like to talk about what
you know and then I'll say email me you
know I mean send me you know somebody
something's for the site or whatever and
you know I'll talk to you you know I
can't always be can you read my script
and it can't always be can you watch my
film because again there's only so many
hours in the day in this you know we all
have other things going on but sometimes
I will also try to connect them with
other people I know if it's something
that I feel like you know maybe I'm not
the best person for them for that
particular thing you know it's it's all
it's everything is sort of an individual
circumstance you know and you have to
just kind of weigh it all out but I can
say that it all starts with the approach
of the other person sure so at Sundance
yeah you're in Park City there might not
be a lot of other things aside the
festival going on so yeah that would be
a great place for someone to meet up but
here in LA because you are involved with
so many things and stage 32 is so much
of your life you would recommend that
maybe someone sent a question via email
instead of so they don't get that
rejection you see what I'm saying they
might take it wrong and it's not that
someone doesn't value their time and and
I make it very I mean I never you know
voided or I'm never not I'm always
honest about it you know I mean if it
really is a time thing it's really a
time thing if it's really that I feel
like I can't help that person in that
particular area if they're looking to
something very very specific I could say
well let me
got it and maybe I could direct you in
the right direction but it's also this
idea that if I can put somebody in a
situation like I was saying earlier if
there's a meet-up going on in town and
in l.a w we constantly have stage three
to meetups happening if I can put them
in a situation where their networking
with 50 people and not just me then I
think that's really you know productive
for them and you know exactly why
they're on the site to begin with
they're on the site to meet other people
and network you know so if I can give
them both you know give them a 5-10
minutes at the event and then give them
a whole support system I'd rather do
that
you